-Welcome!
-How are you?
I´m wonderful.
I´m so happy to have you here.
So this book comes on the cusp
of your 10-year
anniversary of your brand.
-Yes.
-Congratulations.
10 years is amazing.
Thank you. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This book has a lot
of your designs,
a lot of behind
the scenes stuff.
What did you set out to do
with this book?
-Yeah. I mean, it´s 10 years.
It´s a lot of pieces,
but I really wanted to,
you know, it´s time
for kind of escapism.
So I wanted people to feel like
they open this book,
they feel like they´re in a kind
of a a dream fantasy world.
So whatever you´re
kind of feeling,
you kind of just transform
yourself into a new place.
-That´s wonderful.
-Yeah, yeah.
-What a nice thing
for a book to do for you.
-Yeah, yeah. exactly.
I mean, you know,
because I didn´t really
write a lot in it.
It´s very visual.
-[ Laughs ]
-So I felt like I wanted to,
you know,
just make people feel good
and, you know, there´s a lot
of beautiful things in there
that we worked on
over the years
that maybe people
didn´t love in the beginning.
And so I´m glad that we were
able to show them.
-One of -- you have a
design of a dress you made
for Leslie Jones.
You dressed her.
-Yes.
-You continue to dress her.
-Yeah.
-But the relationship --
your relationship with Leslie
started via social media.
Can you tell us this story?
-It did.
-You know, Leslie for her
"Ghostbusters" premier,
which was a huge movie.
You know, she was having a hard
time finding a dress,
which I thought was crazy,
´cause she´s amazing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes, she is.
-She really is.
I mean, she´s so amazing.
And I just thought
that was crazy.
And, yeah, I just responded
with emojis, little hands.
Like, "Hi. I´m here.
I´m happy to dress you."
And, um, and it was really
just casual.
I just really wanted to make
something beautiful for her,
And then we hit it off.
And I think she killed it
on the carpet.
She had her
"Pretty Woman" moment.
-Yeah.
-And looked stunning.
-And then in turn,
she then went to
one of your fashion shows.
-She did.
-This was the first fashion show
that Leslie had ever been to.
-It was.
-And, um...
[ Laughter ]
-...she was very unique.
Were you happy to have someone
with Leslie´s energy
at one of your fashion shows?
-I was.
At first, I thought someone
fell and hurt themselves
because she was screaming
so loud that I just was like...
I mean, and then she came in
the next day.
We were fitting her for the
Emmys and she was like,
"Baby, I thought I was at
the Knicks game."
And I was like, "okay."
-[ Laughs ]
-You know, I just don´t think
she knew what it was
supposed to be.
-Well, I have to think...
-But you guys...
-But I loved it.
-I´ve been to fashion shows.
You do so much work...
-Yeah.
-...and people walk out
in these stunning dresses
and no one reacts.
-Yeah, it´s...
-It´s very what
you would expect.
People are very --
they´re almost trying to stay
as very still,
because they will also
be in backgrounds
of photographs.
-Yeah.
And so everyone is posing.
-So I was --
when I watched this video,
I was very happy with how...
I thought this was
a nice change up
to what you expect
at fashion shows.
Take a look here.
-Yeah! Yeah! Yeah!
Whoo!
[ Laughter ]
Yes!
That´s right.
Come on, now.
come on, now.
Whoo!
[ Screams ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I mean, it was amazing.
I mean, I just loved it so much
because Coco Rocha
was the model there,
and she was like,
"I love Coco so much!"
And I just love her
like grabbing like Gina Gershon
and Patricia Clarkson
who were like, "Who is she?"
You know, so it was just so...
But it made, I think,
everybody in the room just like,
all the fashion people,
who are so annoying,
it just made them, like,
kind of like, let go
and remember that fashion
should be fun
and that´s the whole point.
That´s what this
whole book is about --
that fashion should be fun.
It should be easy
to get dressed.
That´s, like,
the whole point of it.
-Someone who I know
to be a big fan of yours
and who also thought you were
a lot of fun as a person
to watch on television
was Amy Poehler.
And I remember working at "SNL"
and Amy Poehler
did an impression of you
on the show.
-She did.
-And she ran into you the night
before she did it
on television, right?
-Yes, yeah. and I was like --
I was like, 20 years old.
I didn´t really know
what "SNL" was.
Don´t judge me.
[ Laughter ]
And I was like a naive kid.
And I remember her
being nervous and thinking
I was, like, going to judge her.
And I was like, "No, I´m --
I mean, what an honor."
Like, I was a kid.
I was so excited.
And it was, I mean, amazing.
I mean...
-Well, here´s just a,
first of all,
that´s what you looked like
10 years ago.
-Uh-huh, yeah.
-And --
-I look the same.
-And there is Amy Poehler
doing a very, a pretty good,
a pretty good impression.
-I let her borrow my wig.
-[ Laughs ]
-And, no. I mean,
it was amazing.
It was so -- it was really
such a funny sketch.
And I mean, she´s amazing
and so funny.
-Well, you have excellent taste
in comedians.
-Clearly.
-From Poehler to Leslie,
and congratulations on 10 years
and congratulations on the book.
-Thank you so much
for having me.
-It really is wonderful.
-Thank you.